Shin rather jagadeesan from DePaul
University will talk about eventually
we'll talk about them I is ability
eventual consistency thanks for having
me yeah thanks for the invitation so the
context of this talk is the correctness
of distributed algorithms and this is
joint work with my colleague James
Reilly yeah ok so what how my girl will
go about this talk so it spent quite a
bit of time just talking about the
context of the problem this is
distributed data structures we will look
at some simple implementations and the
particular problem will be addressing is
in what sense are these data structures
correct and the ideas of
compositionality and the related idea of
abstraction I'm going to play a key role
in how the correctness definition comes
out and for most of the talk I've
noticed you formal definitions and
asking for your trust but if you do not
or in any case there's a tech report
okay Sam alright so let's set up some
notation so that we can work so let's
think of as just a simple things like an
integer set most of the time you're just
going to have a binary set so we have
sets just with zero and one perhaps let
up will write plus 0 for adding zero to
the set and minus zero for removing the
set and these methods are not going to
return anything and then we have ways to
figure how ways to query the set and
when we query the set we're going to get
back a boolean so I can query if one is
present and if one is present I indicate
that with a check and if one is not
present I you know the false answer I
indicate with an ex
and that sets you will be just one yeah
yeah yeah I'm hesitating because there's
going to be some subtle teen that answer
in the in the data structures we look at
but the intention is that at the level
of the sequential spec we are really
thinking of sets with I'd importance
with an idempotent edition yeah so these
are going to be sets the intention is
these are going to be sets not multisets
so adding zero twice as the same as
adding zero once and we want to think of
this data structure we are it's valid
permitted traces let's think about there
so when we start off there's nothing in
the sets of course we're going to get to
false 40 then we add 0 then we ask for 0
a 0 is there but still one is not there
ok so that's a typical trace we have and
here we have 0 we add a 0 add a one we
ask for a 0 of course we are going to
find it we ask for a one we're going to
find it then mean we remove the one the
0 is still there but the one is not ok
so we're thinking of a data structure as
being specified completely by the traces
its permits ok so that's what really but
what we want to do is we want to look at
distributed implementation subsets ok so
so here's a simple example so here there
yes I have the set is going to be
replicated so the two lines there
indicates two different replicas they're
running separately why we want to do
this we will discuss momentarily and
let's consider some a particular
interaction with this replicated data
structure on so on the top replica we're
going to add a zero check for the zero
and then check for a one couple of times
and on the bottom replica we're going to
add a one and check for the one and
check 40 twice ok and we're going to be
aggressive in doing the accessors what
do I mean by that
so I add the zero ask for the zero I'm
going to find it yeah so it's zero is
going to be there now of course the one
has happened somewhere else so I the
upper replica still doesn't know whether
you know whether that this has happened
but the ants dancers are still going to
be aggressive it's going to say well I
don't know in a one right now so that's
why we have the one which is a false and
when the other replicas does update it
then I come to know that I have a one so
at the end i end up with a one here too
okay and that should have been a zero
that's a typo okay so but when I mean
all the messages have flown around and
the system is quiet we end up with both
sides telling us that we have a zero and
we have a one yeah this is a distributed
system so where do you get to order from
you get order in a couple of different
ways one in the course of a replica
replica evolves you get order and the
second place where you get order is when
you receive messages yeah so so for
example it's here right you're receiving
I'm receiving a message from of the date
of one and often it's useful to just to
think of the underlying partial order
okay and really even though I'll be
drawing lots of diagrams like that the
definitions are really working at the
level of the partial order the structure
of the replicas itself is not important
what is important is the structure of
the partial odd ok so now why are we
doing this why do it well so because
well we don't want to synchronize these
replicas aggressively because
serialization affects the performance it
affects how scalable these things are
and also there is the cap theorem so we
can't have all these three properties
simultaneously so we can't have
consistency where every read receives
the most recent rights availability
where every request receives a response
and where the system works despite
partition tolerance so we can't have all
three simultaneously so watch what is
done in modern distributed systems is
typically a liberalisation of the notion
of consistency okay and we are going to
explore what's going to happen in our
data structure okay so let's look at a
couple of examples okay so this is the
sort of the framework of convergent and
commutative replicated data types we are
still working with sets and when we are
adding zeros and ones clearly those
operations commute okay what do we do
when we have operations which do not
commute okay so for example when I have
a removal of a zero and an additional 40
okay then there are each algorithm
results these conflicts differently the
observed remove set resolves it by
saying that they remove only removes the
ads which it has seen okay so what does
that mean so in order to understand that
let's think of this evolution here this
is a possible evolution following this
algorithm now let's look at the third
replica it gets an update off the ad of
the zero it gets an update of that
another right of the zero it's going to
say yes I have a zero then it gets an
update of the remove the zero okay and
yet it's going to say yes i still have a
zero and why is that that's because the
removal does not remove the ad which it
has not seen okay that's why it's called
observed remove the remove only removes
the ads hitter see ought to think of it
purely in terms of the partial order
what we you know here if you have a
remove and then add which is concurrent
with it there's no order than the ad
Vince ok so to put it all together thus
the set trace which validates that
execution so to speak in some informal
sense is where you have a plus 0 and 0
minus 0 corresponding to that and then
the plus 0 coming from here and the
sense in which the plus 0 wins is that
you know it wins over the minus zero
with which it is concurrent okay and
just to give you one more example
quickly before we launch in just to say
because I'm going to be doing sets all
along its but it's not
do with the subtleties of sets shares an
example of distributed text editors I'm
going to run through this somewhat
quickly so i initialize so here you
think of a B and C s letters let's just
simplify matters a bit let's assume that
we only add characters once okay so i
will not add be twice that's not
essential to the algorithm but it just
makes our view of it simpler so I can't
let me start with a piece of text i
initialize it with c and then in one
replica someone adds a be before the
scene another replica someone adds be
before us and another replica or someone
adds a d after the sea so when we query
will of course we will see BCD Oh came
and everything has happened but now
here's some interesting thing that
happens in one replica one person moves
the D but adds an a before the be okay
and symmetrically in other replicas one
removes the B but adds an e after the
deep ok and now I can ask her what is
the state of the document at this point
okay one consistent to you to take it is
to take that I lender I will be left
with AC e that is to say a is before the
B hence before the sea e is after the d
hence after the sea okay and there is a
you know there is a sequential trace
which validates it and if you look at
the sequential trace which validates it
we notice that it is going to move the
removal of B which is concurrent with
the operation on d after the d write the
removals come after in this sense the
choice made in this algorithm is
symmetric to the choice made in the or
set algorithm here the deletion events
okay so this is a you know these are
sort of two examples to kind of keep in
mind and they now just become you know
the offset looks seemingly simple but
you can build pretty complicated build a
pretty complicated pictures and maybe
just I should just talk a little bit
about this so how I have an audition of
0 and then I add and remove the wand
here I had one and I hadn't
zero yeah and the war said well we
expect to see both elements present why
is that because I have a zero which is
concurrent add 0 which is concurrent
with the remove so I'm going to get that
I have a add one which is concurrent
with that so I expect to see that okay
so there are a lot of several things
that happen in those algorithms here on
the other hand this is still a set in
some deep sense there so for example
there are these are behaviors which the
orcid does not create okay and this
would be atrocious right because we see
the one and then we remove it for no
reason okay or we say 0 is 1 present
without any evidence for it it you know
right or perhaps even more subtly we
have a add and remove and that the honor
between them is resolved differently in
different parts of the distributed
system okay these do not happen in the
o.r set okay so the question we are
going to ask you as well then the
vendors and our set implement a set okay
and what are the constraints okay and
what are you going to size up we want
some basic constraints on our definition
we want a definition to support some
notion of compositionality here I've
written a really simple example so let's
say we have two independent sets and now
I just and I have two implementations of
them they're just they don't interact
with each other and all that I want to
say is well if i run the to
implementation side by side i'm going to
get an implementation of a double set
and this is called compositionality in
this literature highly he and wink this
a different flavor of compositionality
one can ask and in this literature it's
called abstraction and explored by these
authors in the concurrent context so
let's say we have a graph and to
implement a graph I need a set of
vertices and a set of edges ok and now
what do I want to do so I program the
graph against the interface of the sets
ok so I do not know
the implementations now what I want to
know is if been programming against the
interface I have a correct graph then
that should still be that that should
still be correct if i substitute in the
actual implementations right so this is
sort of you know if one part of the
previous slide as being horizontal in
some sense this is vertical you know
there's a refinement yeah you're
replacing the interface by the
implementation okay so we want our
definition whatever it might be to
satisfy these properties also we want it
to be consistent with the single
threaded world if I just have one
replica it must look like a normal set
if I have only one place where my
updates are happening so or social
networks used to be implemented like
this all the updates only happened a car
in California and the only thing we the
only thing we saw on our phones was the
was the reeds okay we were only doing
reads on the phone if we had such a
system than any execution of a system
correct in my sense should automatically
be you know okay and you know there's no
need to read this just think of this as
saying the distributed implementation
should not expose new intermediate
States okay that's what we want and the
reason there's some historical context
to this constraint there are
implementations out there which violate
this constraint okay so people
discovered this after the fact so these
are the things we watch okay and so what
is that first choice we revisit
something which is done and in
traditional concurrency yeah so this is
the world of linearize ability I'm just
drawing an automaton here okay and I
guess in a concurrent world an
implementation is good if all the
executions are accepted by this
automaton okay so what does this
automaton have the states are going to
be labeled by sequences of methods and
the invariant we
maintain is that as we go from one state
to another we will always have proper
proper extensions okay so if i have a
edge from there to there that had better
be a prefix no power and what are the
things on the edges the things on the
edges are pumpsets okay so what does
that mean so let's come here so I start
here nothing has happened I add a zero
so I just have a zero in this case it's
really simple again here I add one I
have one all I could have a zero the one
happens simultaneously and here of
course you have two possible choice i
see that it is 0 1 or 10 it doesn't
matter i'm only showing one here but
let's look at some interesting thing
happened here now here we see a real
palm set in action so here the what I
want to do is I want to say hey can I
accept a check one and a check 0 but I
want to give some extra information
about the check one which is its history
okay so the new events are just the
things that the fringe of the pump set
which is the check one and the check
zero but i want to say the check one is
after the + 0 and the check 0 is after
the plus 1 which means that the only
place where I could stick them in as it
is at the end okay so what I have is
basically sequences of labels and the
transitions are palm sets and the
resulting state has to be consistent you
know really a pre suffix or you know
proper extension of the starting state
and at the pump set everything on the
left they depended on everything on the
right
oh no no that's just parallel I mean two
things happening concurrently I'm just
just a notation for a palm set yeah yeah
this is totally concurrent ok so the way
to read this pumps it is it's a check
one which is independent from a check
zeroed it could happen either order yeah
so there is another order of possible
fear but the check one has to be after
the plus zero what about the plus one no
constraints no constraints here no
constraints Yeah right except that you
know the only way to get a check one is
after the plus one that's why it's for
still yeah all right so this is 0 so
this is our yeah so this is the model
for concurrency so you say a concurrent
implementation is good if it is
simulated by this a tomtom this is the
this is from holy and wink yeah but this
world is too restricted for us okay it's
too restricted for us you know let's go
back to the simple example um we don't
have a way to linearize this yeah so
basically so you know think of how are
we going to place x1 and x0 here we just
know don't have a good place to put it
there okay because we want to put the X
0 but the x0 has to be after the +1 so
it's got to come here that's not
possible sorry we need something a
little more looser okay so what's the
idea daya and the literature is to think
of it let's think of a different model
than the into 280 is that the state's
converge when all the messages have been
delivered so when everything is
delivered we are in a state with 0 and 1
and this is this loose idea is called
eventual consistency and for some kinds
of applications this is fine but it's
you know but from a programming language
perspective this is just not good enough
because it doesn't tell us anything when
there are messages still out there in
the network right so we have a problem
so for example here there's a message
waiting in the network so in principle
the definition allows me all sorts of
silly stuff it here again there are
messages out in the network so it
doesn't check about
doesn't check the inconsistency you see
in the diagram Bella ok are more
generally what is happening we talked
about our earlier constraints we wanted
to satisfy constraints ABC this depth
definition which just imposes this does
not give us enough properties of the
implementations which satisfy them okay
so what are we going to do all right so
there's some prior work some of fish I
was involved in they go along two routes
one routers to say will abandon
sequential specifications okay and that
has the advantage that it's able to
rationally speak about all the
implementations out there oh there is
the other version which takes a secret
which takes the spec seriously but which
is not good enough to handle all the
implementations out there okay so what
we want to do is we want to try to you
know be a little bit more right so what
I want to do it are in the line next few
minutes just tell you give you an idea
of the basic ingredients okay and and
I'm going to do this mostly with
pictures and all right so let's say so
basically they're going to be two ideas
and you know just let's keep that in
mind one is to sort of be more
extensional in a certain sense and the
second is to take the idea that time in
a distributed system is not linear it's
you know you can't have a global time
it's got some deep level it's a partial
order so we gonna try to incorporate
that into our definition okay so right
so first let's say what do I mean by
this we want to be a little bit more
extensional ok so in linear in the
linearize ability state machine right we
just have sequences of labels we do not
worry about whether some of these states
are really by similar to the other
states here and I mean in some intuitive
sense like for example let's think about
let's think about that state in that
state doesn't so have plus 0 there and i
have here all that have done is I have a
I have an access ER for one which is not
there and we know intuitively that these
two states are by similar the only
difference between the evolution from
here and here is going to be sticking in
the X
access early that's a really simple
example yeah and there is a version of
linearize ability which works which does
take this into account you know it's in
the database literature it's called
conflict serializability but we have to
go a little bit further so let's do it
let's do it full hog alright so we'll
follow some what I've done basically
here for those in the know is I'm going
to adopt the old idea from a paper of
Steve Brooks but adapted here so what is
the idea so we're going to take
sequences and we are going to identify
them okay men are we going to identify
that well when they give you the same
sequences of states up to repetition of
states okay so another way of thinking
about it is just to say how I don't have
any new intermediate States okay so what
does that mean so for example here if I
add zero twice here the sequence of
states is well whatever you start here
zero present zero present here here
whatever you start here and 0 present so
really all that has happened is we have
added they have started the 0 present
state twice okay this is Star Trek or
the same thing happens even when we just
have an access okay so what are we going
to do what we're going to do is we go to
identify these states and so if we do
this analysis a little bit in our head
we realize that the equivalence classes
for you know a set over one element is
going to be basically the economic and
elements are just given by the heart of
Nations between plus and minus it
doesn't matter how many minuses you have
there okay so you can draw this diagram
out yeah i can draw this diagram out I
shouldn't hustle you too much about it
because I'm gonna hassle you better now
momentary laser okay somebody this kind
of gives you a sense for what this means
ok now the next thing we do is we're
going to take time seriously ok so we
will explore this in two different ways
the first is that what we notice in the
linearize ability automaton is that you
know there's a very strict prefix
ordering as I
as we walk down you know we are we are
sort of adding up stuff now can we never
lose anything and it's always going
forward okay now what we're going to do
is in a distributed system time works
differently right so when I receive
messages it may not be messaging you
know but I add muss it may be messages
which are happen to come currently to me
okay so we are going to accommodate that
and the way we are going to accommodate
that is that now my transitions may not
just be between prefixes it may be to
sub sequences so let me explain that
okay so let's go back here this is where
i start i remove i'm going to be there
when i add i'm going to be there okay
let's look at the part which looks like
linearize ability so here I get a remove
I add it okay it's afterwards or I get a
remove with a history I still go there
this is just like it used to be we also
have another option which is when i get
a remove it could be a river which is
happening concurrently so in fact it's
put in before ok so the portion of the
diagram here which wasn't in the earlier
linearize ability is this idea that when
i go from a stage to another state I'm
you know this this may not be a prefix
it may just be a subsequence okay so
there is a you know it's the sense in
which so the minus zero here is not
happening after you know but we are
putting it before because it happened
concurrently okay and we see that a
little bit here so let's go back to hear
this is a state which has a plus 0 B
permit 0 now I mean be permitted access
ER which denies the existence of zero
and that's okay and the reason it's okay
is because the place where we would put
the X 0 is before the plus 0 okay so it
gives us a it increases the number of
permitted behaviors in this distributed
system that's what we are doing okay
so that's the sense in which you know we
are liberalizing the notion of time we
are now this ages are not about prefixes
but about subsequences okay and the next
thing we will do and you know this the
last bit we need to do is that the
linearize ability automaton is just
insensitive to independence and so what
do I mean by that well let's think of
the binary set the two values are
independent so what does that mean that
means a trace for a binary set really is
22 totally decoupled traces being a
project down to the zero bitten when you
project down to the one bit okay sorry
now in that sense it's a little bit of
this mazel key which independence there
now what we're going to do here is we go
no this is the thing we are adding to
specifications we're going to enrich
them with the notion of conflict it's
just a binary relation yeah and so far
set what is the binder what is this
conflict is basically the zeros are in
conflict with each other the ones are in
conflict with each other but the zeros
and ones are not in conflict we have a
similar notion for text editor okay now
why does this help us it helps us so let
me just illustrate that with this
example so this was our example okay we
wear this is a valid execution for us
okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
only going to keep the order which comes
from conflicting actions okay so yeah 0
and 1 are not in conflict so I dropped
that order okay and 1 and 0 are not in
conflicts I'm going to drop that order
yeah so basically the thing I've built
here is the restriction of the order I
see there but two conflicting actions
now that and you see that what is the
one you gain from here what do you gain
from yours now you look at that you say
oh I see why it's a set and why is that
because now you can see so let's pick
the one you see there's a one and a
minus one and there's a one here which
is not ordered with respect to those so
I'm allowed to do that similarly that is
the 0 and the 0 and the 0 is not ordered
so I'm allowed to do that okay so
throwing out the order between
conflicting I between you know
independent action
shows me this you know allows me to
identify the spec traces which it
validates ago and the same is true even
with distributed text editor ok now the
net result of all of that is basically
now if you if you think about you know
so this is a portion of the you know the
automaton I'm building between zero and
one well of course it's a product in
this case okay it's the product between
zero and you know the the restrictions
to zero and one basically you have
adding zero and adding mom and I built
up the product that is happening because
in the case of set it's a pure
independence relation and in other cases
it's not going to be it'll be you know
yeah that Omicron will look different
but it's still one can build it so what
is the idea so this is the correctness
criteria I have not defined Sigma for
you but I've told you what goes into
building Sigma let's remember Sigma is
built purely from the spec you give me a
spec with the notion of conflict I'll
build your Sigma and intuitively what
Sigma does is it incorporates these
things and what is the correctness
criterion the correctness criterion is
that an implementation is valid exactly
then the implementation is simulated by
this automaton okay so now what what can
go get let me tell you the results for
what we can do i can give you a more
different characterization more direct
maybe in the tradition you're more
familiar with it satisfies the
constraints i told you about you know
it's sensible for that is to what does
that mean that means if an
implementation satisfies the definition
i've been trying to sketch it will
automatically satisfy these properties
okay it addresses all the crdt examples
in the literature okay it satisfies the
composition axioms both in the set of
the horizontal sands and in the vertical
sense
okay and you know since you're at
Berkeley I should pay a little tribute
to some research was done here and i'll
stop here so let's look at a specific
class of clients okay so these are
called com clients and I here here is
consistency as a logical monotonicity
okay so what does that mean that means
so let's look at data data log programs
okay so that is prologue programs
without function symbols and this is
just you know program to compute
transitive closure I just have these
extra decorations just to indicate at
what node these tuples are stored
otherwise is just data log right so you
know the idea I in in cut in this family
of languages is that you know given such
a program it implies a distributed
algorithm so here you know you take all
these tuples ship them over there and
you know to add to the tuples over there
okay and this competition requires no
coordination okay every every node is
running by itself so the only place
where you know not things become
non-monotonic in their sense it is where
you there you have steak change right so
if I want to go for it for example from
state 0 to state 1 and how do we do
these changes in a logic programming
style we do this with some notion of
time okay so at the zero at the notion
of time we have a state at the next
notion of time we have a different state
okay and this requires in general global
barriers okay but now returning back to
the framework we are thinking about so
if you think of march on clients EG to
me what is happening is there's no race
between the mutaters and accessors and
the work in this work in the hello
strain group is basically sure that lot
of interesting distributed protocols
fall into this category and for this cat
this category of clients any any system
which is correct in our sense
can be thought of totally sequentially
that is you can forget all the
distribution forget all the concurrency
it's just you really can think of it as
a purely sequential so if you have a
distributed set used by a calm client
the calm client can pretend it's a
sequential set okay so as you know all
right um no that's um thank you for your
attention yes in concurrent constraint
programming you have this version of
atomicity at the venue ality can be
implemented at a particular type system
controls constraint system in your cave
oh thats I say I see uh so um I think
the toe I think okay um so I think the
way I view it is that all the general
the pure concurrent constraint
programming in the eventual sense I
think it's you know so I think it falls
into this category of you know of these
comp programs okay on the other hand if
you are thinking of constraint
programming with atomic tells or you're
thinking of constraint programming where
you are actually changing state it
becomes non-monotonic okay so I think so
the definitions i'm giving you apply to
both but in the case for eventually
tells they are you know they're quite
powerful basically
so in in one of the first papers you
mentioned the one by ah so they proved
that way there's ability operational
refinement yeah yeah so what are you
proposing is it then breaking one no
though so yeah so the paper which is so
water horn and I mean the horn paper you
are talking about what I can find it so
they show that linearize ability
coincides with operational refinement
when you have a concurrent operational
semantics what we are searching for is
an analogous theorem for a distributed
operational semantics ok and what do we
have we have one direction of it which
is that correctness in mice ants implies
operational refining the band for a
distributed setting just so the sort of
the statement of the theorem stays the
same but the context has changed we are
moved from concurrent you to distribute
it ok that's the that's the difference
so how does this relate to lattice
variables or co DC so the car so we are
searching for a sort of a so fast okay
concretely any all the examples crdt
algorithms out there they are all
correct in my sense okay so I'm just
giving your definition okay so that
that's the first thing but I think
there's a okay so that's the superficial
answer but I think they're real I think
in a certain sense the definitions I'm
tribus cribe for you I think they
capture the semantic essence of what it
means to be a crdt okay so that where
you are thinking of the way see our
duties are usually presented is
syntactic they tell you here are the
operations and what you have to give me
is what are the operations which are
concurrent and what are the operations
which conflict if they conflict how do
you resolve and i think i'm giving you
the the stile i'm giving you here i
think is so because it's less syntactic
I think it has them it has the
possibility of capturing more things in
that framework but if your thing if
you're thinking purely just see our
duties I think even even from that
perspective I think some of the
properties which I've shown you are not
as well known as they might be a
question are there any protocols used
for example in shared memory mounting
CPU architectures that people have
considered and that have only partial
consistency you know sort of more
relaxed consistency that in fact you're
Samantha's not validate so okay so the
right so the so just as a just to sort
of be careful I did this all of this for
really distributed not shared memory ok
ok now I understand no no I just want oh
I just want I just want to be careful
about so the
I don't know offhand but I'm sure there
are okay so I'm sure there are protocols
and I was just trying to think of
something but I big away as I'm certain
that there are shared memory protocols
which are not have proposed all kinds of
crazy things yeah yeah yeahs now because
you get it might be useful to apply
these tools to analyzing them not I
agree I agree it's just so the reason I
mean so we were thinking about it from a
distributed end and there are the there
are fewer constraints on execution at
the distributed end so that's why I'm so
I'm sure that our shared memory
protocols here all right oh well thank
you again
[Applause]